okay we're on overtime here are some of
your questions this the CDC the Center
for Disease Control predicts that Ebola
will affect 550,000 people by the end of
the year shouldn't we be more concerned
well we just sent we just said how many
troops to three thousand three thousand
that's a pretty big 30 million dollars
to the CDC and 58 million for Barda to
come up with a vaccine so we've done
everything that we're supposed to be
doing but I've never heard that number
but God doesn't think we're doing enough
so we go to Obama because Obama what
Ebola has replaced Isis at the border
for Fox News at least temporarily well
you can say that because here's a
question it says does the Mexican border
pose a real threat to national security
to justify its increased militarization
by Rick Perry I don't know if what they
are they talking about
Isis at the border like Trent Franks are
they talking about the Guatemalan kids
who are looking for a peanutbutter
sandwich at the border and who no one's
talking about anymore no they seem to
have disappeared that's good and that
was just a loophole because they wanted
to make sure Mexican kids didn't come so
in the original bill that said you know
we're gonna expedite sort of in any sort
of consideration of people coming here
for asylum we want to do it but just
make sure no Mexican kids and so all of
the Coyotes then went south and said
we'll do it for Central American
Guatemalan kids and that's when the
influx started not the Coyotes in my
back here they are man knows actually I
just kidding I just went down to
Honduras and met with a lot of these
kids and the families the crazy thing
about it that yeah oh you went down to
Honduras yeah LCL alone Oh anywhere I
know I know we already go with me yeah I
know you do and it's never gonna happen
jack
hey you won't travel with my how totally
hang out I wanted Beverly Hills hotel
anytime you want but I mean I admire
that you go to Rwanda to help the
gorillas and the children don't forget
there is a little himesh open of the
gorillas I think I think helping the
gorillas is humanity well it is but I'm
these kids what's interesting Wendell is
that the Coyotes will say to them we'll
give you three attempts give me four
thousand five thousand dollars and they
sometimes they make it and sometimes
they don't they keep doing it but
they're making millions upon millions of
dollars more money than that and
smuggling drugs at the moment what's not
being talked about though is that all
these people are a profit Center talk
about for-profit colleges yep for-profit
prisons the for-profit prison system in
Arizona so is one of the most vicious
things in the entire world yet again
shareholders enriched by filling prison
beds yeah I mean the immigration laws in
Arizona are their key money making
provision far be it for me to pile on
the Republicans but I must say one of
the worst ideas in the whole Republican
category is the idea that everything
should be for-profit the free market
always knows best
certainly prisons we could healthcare in
prisons why sick and dying people and
prisoners shouldn't those two tools that
you're naturally for the profit motive
is that so much to have yeah but the
problem that leavening will be
I know my place I will defend profit
profit is a good thing it is wasting
every let me say on in this case then
your total icing estimate prison is
controlled by the government
it is a bid situation and the health
care is still provided by the government
and how there are soft invited by the
government yes it is you have to buy
insurance ask a risk and impress know in
a private or 500 yeah well I mean you're
the whole idea product that the GOP is
working on it's what you know general
Powell is talking about is majority
becomes mine all right they're trying to
coalesce all of the power money
influence as we become minorities but in
privatization of all of our government
Treasury in every field so when we put
our people in office we control this
privatization although in 20 years we're
minority we are still in control of its
power American is the greatest country
in the world the most exceptional the
most fantastic people and yet we have
more of our own people in prison than
any other country we've built how do we
got away see where that bills are 28
prisons in California the last 30 years
and only one new public university that
just goes to show you by the way closing
is crowding out education there yeah now
and I'm a son of a college professor I'm
from a college town I think absolutely
we've got invest in the education
there's no debate at all one thing I
want to point out is that me here for
the Belgrave let me say this about the
student loan program as you know that
was done in 2007 under Nancy Pelosi in
the Democrat leadership the the program
that you're criticizing John Kline for
was a Democrat package passed by the
Democrat House Democrat Senate signed by
President Obama it was a bill to cap
interest rates and make them fix not
variable it but it's a smart it's still
in effect today yet because when you
change no area vote rate and if it was
changed today it would have been signed
by President Obama and passed by Harry
Reid and it was an Advil that we opposed
anyway right but I'm telling you the
I mean you have to admit that it was a
Democrat where we say Democrat when when
you know the word is democratic go mud
down the subtle it my job is equal time
to pay for what and I've been I know
that's a subtle dig the Democrat plans I
don't even get it
I don't even know why yeah I'm saying
Democratic Democrat like plus Leesville
it's Democrats up curiously why are we
arguing why is the big political debate
about how high student interest loan
rates didn't just rates should be why
are why are we not invading building
more universities you were yes will
Australia done you were born up 1984 I
don't II natey I paid three hundred
fifty dollars a semester at the
University of Wisconsin the school that
the UC system here was free until Ronald
Reagan decided those up and kids
shouldn't get to go to college the
greater their
Reagan said that the federal government
should not be in the business of making
young people rich and subsidizing their
profits so lately trained on it on the
entire and that's why the GOP is very
good at rhetoric because they loved
Ronald Reagan for all of his rhetoric
and and and he spoke to poor white folk
that's who the GOP folks is a poor white
folk because you might become a member
of the rich white guy car you say and
the ones trying to say you say so that's
a larger portion of my learning
college-educated panelists here are you
saying a truck driver who makes 30,000 a
year who did not go to college should
subsidize some future doctor and lawyer
who did yes with a low way because we
have actually on there and you know what
because we actually decide that the
values in our country the blue because
it pays itself back many times over bad
scholars should subsidize the white
collar we light collars you know our
science to it should enjoy everyone no
not like a truck driver who makes 30,000
a year should he subsidize the future
daughter what I thought why are you
condescending to the cousin on college
truck fire yes here's a question here
she might want his camera decided we're
not gonna divorce it what this type of
education you're gonna get I don't know
question knowing something some why not
paint in countries colleges free hey I
just want to point out in some countries
hey Oscar and you know we have 11
aircraft carriers nobody else has any
like if I only had eight we probably
could send everybody to college
and I don't think Finland would invade
and by the way speaking of Ronald Reagan
and we were talking about the Middle
East before you know in 1983 when the
barracks was bombed in Beirut George
Bush the first went over there is the
vice president of time he stood in the
rubble and he said we will not be cowed
by terrorists and then we cut and ran
what do you think about that well I you
know I I tend to agree with you because
listen USS Cole 17 Americans killed
under the Clinton as president it was
called it was called a criminal act on
the bombing of the embassy in Nairobi
criminal at the 1993 bombing of the
World Trade Center a criminal act
instead of this was an act of terrorism
what did it bring to us 9/11 we should
have done something
so you're saying Reagan was the
beginning of the problem uh I would say
that there were mistakes that were made
no we were always the last of chances
what it's about remain Reagan mistakes
were made he could not have made them
all right thank you everybody Thank You
pana we'll see